president trump and i was there i i was
literally negotiating between the white
house and congress uh
the president had me here and then i
would go across the street and speak to
speaker pelosi speaker pelosi would tell
me to go back to the white house
so i was negotiating between the white
house and congress on this there was a
great deal president trump even
surprised me
with the number of dreamers he increased
it times two
he went from 800 000 to 1.6 million
dreamers
pastor sam we're gonna give dreamers a
pathway to citizenship
as long as i get my wall and protect the
border and stop all illegal immigration
and i went back to the speaker we
negotiated something and then chuck
schumer came along and said
we're not going to give president trump
a win that do your due diligence on this
it's been extensively covered
i want to shift to immigration because
that's sort of how you got on my radar
so there's obviously
a lot going on at the southern border
right now
i'll just sort of give you a vague
question here which is how should we be
thinking about what's going on here
because it's getting
very very difficult to even understand
what's remotely true meaning okay did
obama
start the cages and are the cages worse
because of trump and then they got
better and now
it's like everything feels like just
such a mess
so i can i can give you not anecdotally
what i can give you from being involved
since george w bush uh i worked at the
bush administration matter
as an advisor i worked with karl rove
directly and
i worked with obama for eight years on
this matter and i worked for president
trump
on this matter and other matters by the
way so here it is
wow this is chaotic on on multiple
levels let me lay it out for you
we have the ability to solve this we can
solve this the immigration crisis
is just the outcome of political
expediencies
on both sides of the aisle george w bush
had a great proposal should have passed
didn't pass
a couple of people from the republican
side put a halt on that and that's a
shame
during the obama administration
president obama made health care a
priority
sacrificed immigration and that's a
shame
and he had two years by the way to do it
where he had control yeah he could have
done whatever he wanted
boom so this is the fault of again
you know healthcare trumps immigration
president trump and i was there i
i was literally negotiating between the
white house and congress uh
the president had me here and then i
would go across the street and speak to
speaker pelosi speaker pelosi would tell
me to go back to the white house
so i was negotiating between the white
house and congress on this there was a
great deal president trump even
surprised me
with the number of dreamers he increased
it times two
he went from 800 000 to 1.6 million
dreamers
pastor sam we're gonna give dreamers a
pathway to citizenship
as long as i get my wall and protect the
border and stop all illegal immigration
and i went back to the speaker we
negotiated something and then chuck
schumer came along and said
we're not going to give president trump
a win that do your due diligence on this
it's been extensively covered so what's
what do we do now right now in the
border we have a crisis
guess what the cages were built by
president obama's administration yeah
there it's just the fact the case of
fact they they were from the obama
administration as a matter of fact
even the pictures that were used against
president trump that were from the obama
administration
so that a lie that became not true
that was perceived to be truth by mass
media
currently right now they're in the same
places
that president biden and kamala harris
spoke against in every single debate
they are actually putting
young men and women boys and girls in
the same identical places i kid you not
the same identical facilities with the
same identical conditions
it actually seems far worse aren't
aren't they more packed now it is
it's way more packed than i should know
i've traveled to these centers i've been
there
i've interviewed i've interviewed custom
border patrol agents
many of them attend our churches so i
even did some sidebars i went hey guys
tell me the truth just as people of
faith please tell me the truth
off the record they went hey hey pastor
sam we're not like setting this up
to try to convince you of anything this
is the reality so i've been there
the reality is right now under the biden
administration there is a greater crisis
than ever during the trump
administration as it pertains to
children
coming in it is tragic i mean the
stories are
heartbreaking babies toddlers we're
talking about
toddlers it's a pastor and as a dad
it's heartbreaking to see the images and
this is because the biden administration
gave a
wink and a nod for people to come over
they did they can't
deny it they did and now we're reaping
the consequences
but there is a solution and here it is
here's a proposal number one we need to
secure our border
we're a sovereign nation open borders
doesn't work
open borders invites sex trafficking
the drug cartels they are smiling the
cartels are smiling right now
this idea this notion is so
anti-american and as a pastor committed
to ending human and sex trafficking
i repudiate what's currently taking
place at the border
we need to secure the border stop all
illegal immigration
we want people coming here legally not
illegally and we can't have it both ways
we can't
we can't permit more people coming here
illegally breaking the law
and then we're telling people that they
must wear masks which is
right so there's a segment of society
that has to adhere to the law
yet there's a group of individuals that
don't have to adhere to or obey the law
that lack of continuity subconsciously
creates
a construct which leads to behavior
that produces chaos and anarchy a lack
of coherency right
so we have to make up our minds let's
protect the border stop illegal
immigration and we can do it even
not just through a physical wall
infrared technology
satellite imaging come on we could read
the license plate from a car in
afghanistan from a satellite
we can stop thousands crossing over the
rio grande backpacks
so we have the technology to do it let's
do that let's stop all illegal
immigration
the second thing we must do is get the
dreamers on a pathway
to become citizens just the dreamers now
because i still believe the kids should
not pay for the sense of their parents
some of your audience would disagree
with that i just find it to be logical
if you were brought over when you were
three four five years old
i mean come on right and now you're and
now you're 20 years old are you kicking
these people out of the country and you
grew up here you don't even speak
spanish
you know you grew up in our in our
educational system it's
let's find a pathway as long as you're
not involved in various activities
you're not again you're not involved in
gangs
et cetera et cetera let's speak let's
let's have these individuals become
citizens but those their parents
that's where i differ where i'm even
maybe too conservative
for some of my friends on the right i
don't think that
the parents who came here illegally
should ever become citizens so
what do you do with it there's a there's
a price to pay we give them a green card
so this is what we do if you're not
living off government entitlement if
you're not living off welfare and i know
that you're you're probably using false
social security numbers that is a crime
you know you're going to have to
recognize the fact that you broke the
law that you have been breaking the law
you should be paying some fines but
you've been we've been here for 20 25
years
working and some of these individuals
are some of the hardest working
individuals i know i live in california
so that's not true that's giving
speaking truth to power and they attend
our church some of the most beautiful
people on the planet they should have
come here legally by the way
all right did that ship sale yes but
there's a price to pay
we're going to give you a green card
stay in america you no longer have to
fear being deported
but you're never going to become a
citizen there's a price to pay
how in the world can we compensate
people
that came here illegally with
citizenship for crying out loud
when there are people waiting in line
legally in nations
attempting to come into this country the
right way it's just wrong
so my my proposal which i gave to
president trump
and i gave it to a number of senators
that are just of close friends
i said here's the proposal i call it a
just integration solution
and i think the vast majority of
americans would embrace this and matter
of fact i know because we did some
polling and they actually would
including
members of the freedom caucus the most
conservative individuals who say that
sounds fair
that sounds fair all right there's a lot
of different ways we could go here so
what do you think the wink
that you're talking about the biden
administration wink what do you think it
really is all about so if they're
telling you
because they're kind of like don't come
maybe come in a few weeks you can kind
of come but what do you think they're
actually trying to accomplish with the
wink are they trying to get all these
people there and do they have any
intention of actually
doing what you said which is we've got
to secure a border and it's the right of
every sovereign nation to do so
now i i don't think and i say there's a
great deal deference i don't think the
current administration has any viable
commitment it's not
i can't measure it if you can't measure
it and it's not legit
as it pertains to this outcome i don't
see any
any sort of evidence that this
administration is committed to
protecting the sovereignty of america
not it's it's there are many open border
operatives that come from the heart
ideological left
and right now unfortunately they seem to
have the ear of our president
and and it is unfortunate it is so i
think the objective
is there's twofold there are those and i
can't judge
everyone across the board i'm looking at
political outcomes
there is a group of individuals that
really
with a great heart would love to see
america you know emerge
as the the phrase on the statue of
liberty the the place that
of refuge and hope for people that are
broken around the world
but that's utopia we we can't open up
for the entire world
we just don't have the bandwidth we're
not the new jerusalem if you're an
evangelical or a christian
you know we're this is not heaven this
is not the new earth
whatever you want to call it in your
theological worldview we're not there
uh so we can't we have to protect our
borders
the second thing is and this seems a
little bit more complicit
but i know there's some conversation
with leadership on the hard left
there is an attempt to change america
with more voters there is and it sounds
oh that's that's that's just wild
sam no it isn't again some people are
doing it with good intentions
yet napoleonic a bit a bit of an utopic
sort of worldview
and then there are some that have a more
i would call it wicked
sort of imperative which is let's change
the demographical landscape
to such a degree that we're going to
secure power
for generations to come that's wicked
because you're dealing with human lives
beautiful people created in the image of
god that are seeking a better day we
want them to do it legally
i believe immigrants are a blessing and
not a burden if they come here legally
but i believe it is wicked and morally
reprehensible to use human beings as
political pawns
so did you get any sense that
trump just could not or i guess this is
the sense you got trump just could not
get anything done because no matter what
he was going to offer that at the end
even if pelosi kind of nodded to it
schumer was going to blow it up or
i don't even have to blame schumer but
just that the machine was just going to
say we're not going to give the guy a
win sure he's going to double the amount
of dreamers
but we're not going to give him a win on
the wall and this is just how
bad politics is that deal was
was one of the best deals that i've seen
since working on this since 2006.
it really was and just and and i met
with po
potus with president trump on this um
and i met with general kelly secretary
nielsen back then
and i was blown away i'm going like what
just happened
like what and and his commitment
uh amazing and even when president trump
would speak to hispanic americans to
latino americans
he would repeat that uh you know and and
i'm going whoa
this is not part of the collective sort
of media exacerbated narrative of a
racist president
it's not i mean you know which is it
right and what he offered was a
great deal that should have again
democrats just said
no because we can't give him a win with
the latino community
and we can't give them a win on
immigration i mean that just destroys
our narrative
and it's a shame because again they're
playing politics with human lives
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell